how do you guys feel because we were in
Boston mhm and we're not thanks for
coming out Boston that looks fun it's
amazing what an amazing night um also I
was like so scared cuz I had completely
lost my voice two days before you were
sick I saw yeah two days before I
couldn't even talk yes and then they got
me on steroids and stuff and I was be
able to PE get it out but anyway and
we're on stage and like it gets a you
know I love it when Andrew does an Asian
accent yeah he's good at them yeah but
it's fun it's fun yeah but you know I
was on stage and I'm like in my mind I'm
like um do how do other Asians feel
about it oh yeah right so I'm going to
ask these guys well if you're not there
as a kind of a gauge I think it's maybe
a little different no yeah yeah maybe
but it's like it's also not malicious
it's not malicious but what do you how
do you feel about white dudes doing
Asian act it has to be funny and Andrew
does a very funny one okay good that's
my that's my it has to be fun the intent
is not to uh put down it's just it's
always to serve the bit I feel like
right yeah and funny funny wins I mean I
I've always wanted to do comedy that
reaches everyone you know what I mean
that's just been my thing what's your
demo right now like black mils what are
you working no no if you're but anyway
when I'm in the you know in front of
them and I you know he does it I makes
me laugh but you know in my mind I'm
like oh there's not a lot of Asians here
is that why but not because when we do
tiger belly a lot of Asians show up so
it's like yeah yeah too many someone say
now there is
something spread the wealth you know
Seattle's a big place um thank you for
doing that by the way you were so great
man that was a oh yeah dude you saved
our life yeah you saved our life dude
that night so I don't if you guys know
but when tiger belly did one on the road
in Seattle you know when we do it in LA
and in Austin you know we have there's
so many people that can go up on stage
with us cuz we need help so in Austin we
had like the are you Garbage Guys they
were already out there Jesse Johnson she
was already out there and a bunch of
people but we were so worried about
Seattle we have have so many games to
play and we need that extra boo Bo you a
boost right and then um when I found out
you were in town and you helped us that
night you it was you and Amanda Knox and
you guys really um made it special and
fun D thank you so did you have fun that
night so much fun yeah I mean I was just
uh Magic yeah it was so fun I mean
there's such a even though it been a u a
minute since we'd all like jammed like
that it's like it's it's second nature
man once you get out there too and and
also I felt comfy to be able to you guys
all kind of were like yeah just like you
know add like do whatever so if I didn't
feel comfy to like um you know do what I
uh what I hopefully do and like you know
do and then also check in like there are
times when you would go all right right
ask the [__] like when we were asking
questions for the uh was it two truths
and a lie um you know sometimes I was
getting a little long and you like just
shut the [__] up and ask a question yeah
but that but you did it in a funny way
um I just wish you guys were doing that
CU that was only a short run right yeah
we want to I I want to do more yeah
we're going to do more maybe San
Francisco Hawaii the two oh yeah yeah go
the places where that are fun and where
you got where the Asians are where the
Asians are San Francisco Hawaii I didn't
want to say but yeah Toyo it's a
different kind of show you know and it's
like you know you know people ask you
know am I ever going to quit Tiger Bell
I'll never will unless these guys say
we're out yeah why would you don't leave
man yeah I'm worried about you dude hey
man no sometimes dude who would leave
first probably me yeah wow I can tell to
do what work at Best Buy probably yeah
just Mi it up no no I I don't know how
do you feel now I feel good the biggest
the thing for if I did leave would be
it' be because of my marriage